une délégation européenne est donc
arrivée ce matin à Kiev plusieurs ou
responsables le président du Conseil
Charles Michel ou encore la chef de la
Commission européenne sont du voyage
good to be back c'est bon d'être de
retour à tweeter il y a quelques
instants à son arrivée Ursula à vendre
qui effectue ici son 4e déplacement
depuis le début de l'offensive russe à
la veille d'un sommet européen les
objectifs sont multiples donnés des
perspectives à l'Ukraine envoyer un
signal politique fort il sera question
aussi pendant cette visite de l'aide
militaire Caroline de Camaret qui voyage
au sein de la délégation officielle nous
expliquer pendant le transfert en train
les enjeux de ces prochaines heures
écoutez
l'Union européenne voyage vers l'Ukraine
et elle voyage en force une quinzaine de
commissaires autour de la présidente
jeudi à Kiev pour redire l'engagement de
cette commission auprès des Ukrainiens
qui se sont vues attribuer le statut de
candidats des juin qui ne vont pourtant
pas adhérer à l'UE en pleine guerre très
rapidement mais qui ont fait des efforts
qui sont reconnus d'ailleurs l'aide
effectivement de l'Union est très
substantielle 18 milliards d'euros dont
3 milliards ont d'ores et déjà été
versées pour soutenir l'économie 3
milliards aussi de facilités pour la
paix afin de faciliter l'achat
d'armement par les Ukrainiens ils ont
bénéficié aussi de beaucoup d'armements
européens conventionnels et désormais de
chars puisque dans la foulée des
Américains les Allemands ont débloqué
aussi leurs chars léopard et puis
dernière bonne nouvelle pour les
Ukrainiens effectivement on reconnaît
leur vocation européenne à travers la
facilitation d'envoi de céréales on
reconnaît aussi qu'il faut les aider sur
l'énergie qui est régulièrement coupée
dans les villes et l'Europe s'intéresse
à raccorder tout ce réseau et puis
surtout il y aura vendredi dans la
foulée un grand sommet
Ukraine avec aussi le président Charles
Michel la présidente vanderleyen et le
président
Zelinski sur la photo de famille